super Tuesday finally here it's a super
morning super Tuesday part two super
Tuesday part three another Super Tuesday
they're called the asella primary ASA is
that how you say it the esela the
primaries it's hard not to miss it it's
hard not to miss it all right happy
Hillary Clinton's superest Tuesday sport
fans no matter what happens in
California New Jersey and the other
states that are voting tonight Hillary
Clinton will stand on a stage at the
Navy Yard in Brooklyn later this evening
and declare that she is now finally her
party's presumptive nominee we'll talk
about that historic moment in a moment
but first after another 24 hours of
scathing reactions to Donald Trump's
comments about US federal judge Gonzalo
curiel the Republican presumptive
nominee released a statement late this
afternoon that reads in part quote it is
unfortunate that my comments have been
misconstrued rud as a categorical attack
against people of Mexican heritage I am
friends with and friends with and employ
thousands of people of Mexican and
Hispanic desent the American justice
system relies on Fair and impartial
judges all judges should be held to that
standard I do not feel that one's
Heritage makes them incapable of being
impartial but based on the rulings that
I have received in the Trump University
civil case I feel justified in
questioning whether I am receiving a
fair trial I do not intend to comment on
this matter any further end quote
Trump's statement seems to be a response
to as I said another wave of
condemnation from fellow Republicans
Senator Tim Scott the upper chambers's
only black Republican is calling Trump's
remarks quote racially toxic Senator
Lindsey Graham all but urged his
colleagues to unor their party's
presumptive nominee and Illinois Senator
Mark Kirk basically did that he's
running for re-election this year and
said that he would support Trump for
president he put out a statement today
saying quote I cannot and will not
support my party's nominee for president
and after denouncing Trump's words a few
days ago house Speaker Paul Ryan and
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
spoke to reporters in DC today and once
again Express their disapproval in the
strongest possible
terms I disavow these requirements I
regret those comments that he made I
don't
think claiming a person can't do their
job because of their race is sort of
like the textbook definition of a racist
comment I think that should be
absolutely disavowed it's absolutely
unacceptable we have plenty of issues
and my advice to our nominee would be to
start talking about the issues that
American that the American people care
about and to start doing it now in
addition to that U it's time to quit
attacking various people that you
competed with or various minority groups
in the country and get on
message As Trump instructed during that
conference call that Bloomberg politics
reported on yesterday his allies have
been on cable TV all day trying to get
this thing under control argu that there
was no racial element in Trump's
criticism of Judge curiel some
surrogates like former Reagan Stafford
Jeffrey Lord actually accused Trump's
critics of being the ones using racist
statements in this
fight let me make no bones about it
speaker Ryan is wrong and speaker Ryan
has apparently switched positions and is
now supporting identity politics which
is racist I I mean I I am astonished
Aston you're accusing Paul Ryan you're
you're accusing Paul Ryan of racism I am
accusing anybody anybody who believes in
identity politics which he apparently
now does are playing the race card the
Republican establishment is playing this
Senator McConnell is playing this these
people have have you know run and hid
and borrowed the Democratic agenda of
playing the race card so Mark um up
until this afternoon in the Trump
statement uh the contro this controversy
did not seem to be losing steam at all
if anything it seemed to be gathering
momentum going forward uh with all the
stuff that's happened uh but my question
to you is now that Trump has addressed
the matter with this statement um do you
think that is the beginning of him
putting it behind him this will put some
of it behind him for some people it's
too soon to say just how much this will
cure what is clear is that he can't
unring the bell of what he said
particularly with you know this is as
close to an apology as he gets but it's
not a full throat apology he basically
says I'm sorry if you mistakenly didn't
understand what I was saying a lot of
Republicans will be spooked by this they
knew the guy said controversial things
but they hoped it wouldn't be this
controversial and offive to so many and
they also that he would after he became
the presumptive nominee I think that we
will see over the next few days how he
behaves he's going to try not to do this
again but this has spooked a lot of
Republicans well yes because it seems to
suggest that he has no capacity for
self-control um he brought this the
whole thing entirely on himself and then
continued as we discussed yesterday to
keep going and going and going now
apparently he looked at the chaos and
sort of just tried to slam on the brakes
he didn't apologize guys as you know
well saying that you're sorry that all
you misconstrued my comments is not an
apology at all and you know there's
nothing in it that explains how when he
said before he's hispanic and therefore
he's can't be impartial in my case how
you didn't walk that back all he says
now is he's still impartial he's still
not impartial so he doesn't explain why
he's not capable of rendering impartial
Justice in this statement whatsoever and
he doesn't really even walk back the
comments that he made except for saying
I'm sorry some of you got this wrong I I
think that Republican will still be
freaked by this for a long time I think
the ones who want to be behind him will
be happy that he seems to have come to
his senses at least momentarily and I
don't think that they will think I don't
think they will be looking at this and
saying oh well everything's all fine now
Ryan prus the chairman of the party who
is under extraordinary pressure to clean
this up because he's one of the few
people who has regular interaction with
Trump he said early in this cycle for
the Republicans to win the White House
back given their performance in the last
six presidential elections they needed
to run a perfect campaign amongst the
things that this illustrates is Trump's
not going to run a perfect campaign and
Republicans are going to have to decide
how to Grapple with it the condemnation
of the Speaker of the House of his own
party's presumptive nominee is
extraordinary get used to it there's
going to be more of it all right on the
Democratic side Washington DC primary
did not happen until next week but the
other last six states in this very
dramat dramatic nominating contest are
having contest today last night the
Associated Press and a NBC and others
reported that according to their
calculations Clinton had reached the
mega Majestic magic number the 2383
delegates some pledge and some super
that she needs to advance the general
election as her party's standard Bearer
for weeks it's been clear that Clinton
was almost certainly going to become the
first female Presidential nominee of a
major political party a national and
international Milestone but that doesn't
make this moment arriving even though
it's not official yet any less historic
out on the west coast Bernie Sanders is
going to take the stage to rally tonight
in Santa Monica California and almost
certainly say that his campaign has
exceeded all expectations accomplish
more than anyone could ever have dreamed
of and that he'll be on that point he'll
be on those points he'll be 100% correct
what we don't know at this point though
is what Sanders's next move will be how
Clinton is going to handle her Victory
exactly and what the delegate dance
between between the two of them will
look like as it plays out over the next
few days so we know that Sanders has
said and his team has said he's going to
the convention they've said he's going
to go through certainly the DC Prime we
we know he says he's going to keep up
the fight you and I have discussed at
length the fact that that may change but
just talk about how you see the dance
between Clinton and Bernie Sanders
playing out starting this evening and
into the coming weeks well there's a
third party now involved between those
two there's a third party involved in
the dance and that's President Obama we
know he talked to Bernie Sanders over
the weekend had a lengthy got a Nobel
Peace Prize had had a lengthy phone call
with Sanders um and I think the white
house right now is is being differential
President Obama wants want to endorse
Hillary Clinton as soon as possible um
but they're being differential because
they recognize that there is a there are
negotiations and conversations happening
between the Sanders campaign and the
Clinton campaign on exactly this
question how this dance is going to play
out I think President Obama will have
endorsed Hillary Clinton by the end of
the week she not won't he's not going to
endorse her tonight but one of these
days before one of these week days that
are left Wednesday Thursday Friday that
endorsement will happen but other things
will happen before that happens and
those things will be between the Clinton
and Sanders people and I think what
happens in California will affect that
negotiation of how Sanders and Clinton
choreograph the denim mu here yeah I
mean look if Bernie Sanders could take
his fight to the convention in
Philadelphia if he could keep his
supporters rallied if he could if he
could uh have his name put in nomination
if he could see if there were any
developments that maybe would cause
superdelegates to turn against Hillary
Clinton he would do it for sure the
question is can he be persuaded that
staying in Damages her and is there a
way to stay in without damaging her my
gut still is that if he can figure out a
way to do that and he can be convinced
and can convince people around him that
he's not going to hurt her chance of
winning a general election I think he
wants to stay in because you and I have
said before this is not from his point
of view and his supporter's point of
view Brand X and brand y these are two
different visions of what the party
should be and how our politics needs to
change he may go into a passive campaign
mode but I think what's true is that
it's clear to me now at least that
Sanders does not cares less about the
platform and if you look at the people
who put on the platform NE committee you
can tell that he's not that serious
about trying to fix the Democratic
platform to his liking I think he cares
about reforming the process and I think
the argument that uh President Obama and
others around him will be making and
that the Clinton people are too is that
he has a higher degree of Leverage if he
gets on board than if he holds out and
that by holding out as everyone else in
the party piles and behind her he may be
left behind and lose leverage that may
change his thinking as much as anything
else here's the greatest cop out ever
I'd be surprised at no outcome
anything's possible okay uh prior's USA
the Super PAC supporting Hillary Clinton
is out with a new TV ad about that time
that Donald Trump apparently mocked a
New York Times reporter's physical
disability we will talk to Guy Cecil The
Man Behind that ad next but first we'll
have this quick work and word from our
[Music]
sponsors
[Applause]
[Music]
in commemoration of spring and the start
of the unofficial general election
priorities USA the pro Clinton Super PAC
has a new TV ad hitting the Airways in
Ohio Virginia Florida and some other
general election battlegr States it
features the Ohio parents of a child
with a rare physical disability talking
about their outrage about that moment a
few months ago when Donald Trump seem to
imitate Serge kovaleski a New York Times
Reporter who also has a physical
disability joining us from Washington
now to discuss that new ad the
Democratic race and oh so much more the
co-chair and chief strategist of
priorities USA guy Cecil and here with
us to talk about the Democratic race
Margaret talb our senior White House
correspondent for Bloomberg politics
Margaret and guy thank you for joining
us guy um early advertising we've talked
about this before are you convinced that
you the campaign and other Clinton
allies can effectively end this race
before the conventions by defining
Donald Trump on your
terms no I expect that we're going to
continue to advertise all the way
through the end and that that's what
will be required because not every voter
is fully paying attention to the general
election they're out living their lives
uh taking care of their kids but we do
know that as the primaries come to a
close that people are starting to pay
attention and we want to make sure that
we're filling in the blanks on uh Donald
Trump and his view of the presidency his
view of the world and his view of most
Americans guy I'd like to ask you this
question real quick before I turn to
Margaret what's the percentage
likelihood that we're going to see an ad
out of your organization that has Donald
has Paul Ryan saying that Donald Trump's
comments about Judge curiel were the
textbook definition of
racist better than Ean
right how's that that's fabulous I'm
sure 100% accurate uh Margaret we were
just talking about uh about the the
dance between between uh Clinton and
Sanders and that will also involve
President Obama as we go forward a bunch
of endorsements that Hillary Clinton is
going to get right she's going to get
Barack Obama's endorsement she's GNA get
Joe Biden's endorsement she's GNA get a
whole bunch of endorsements just talk
about like what you think the timing is
for that and how those things are likely
to play out so we know that Hillary
Clinton is going to be uh holding major
campaign appearances next week in Ohio
and in Pennsylvania not just in Ohio but
in the place where the Republicans are
having their convention that's going to
be an important day for her and as many
of those endorsements as she can get
locked down before before then out in
public before then and perhaps on stage
with her then uh so the next well week
six days will be a really big time frame
and you assume that she going to do a
public event at some point there with
President Obama in that like in this
week in this week stretch not tomorrow
in New York but but at some point soon I
would assume that they're trying to do
that within the next week uh or at least
uh to get certainly The Joint uh the
endorsement in the next couple of days
back if you look back in 2008 she was
within three or 4 days about 4 days
after had clinched the nomination she
was publicly standing behind him but it
was a couple weeks after that before
they had their first big appearance
together and there's a lot of stage
craft that goes into that uh but there
was not the same concern you know really
back then that there could be the sort
of slow drag on him he had so much
momentum so much energy and enthusiasm
behind him in a way that she just hasn't
yet hey guy you've you've followed
politics for a long time and worked in
it for a long time you ever seen any
candidate for any office do the kind of
thing Donald Trump has done in the last
few days regarding uh Trump University
and judge
cural no and I haven't seen that many
human beings behave in such a horrible
way and putting out a statement that
says um not I'm sorry not I was wrong
but that some of my best friends are
Hispanic is not an acceptable response
to what can only be described directly
and simply as a racist attack on an
American judge and the idea that he
could put out a statement that was
clearly written by somebody else and
that that's going to solve his problem I
think is uh pretty shortsighted this is
going to stick with him I think for a
while Margaret well I think it's
interesting the role that the the
judicial system is playing in this
election so far first with the Supreme
Court thing and now with this but this
is certainly a problem for Donald Trump
and for Hillary Clinton it's a moment
where she may want to be taking a
Victory lap like hey I'm the first woman
but it's also a moment where she want
just want to get out of the way and let
Donald Trump's problems unfold without
interruption for a couple of days what
do you think about the the question of
Leverage and and what Senator Sanders is
is is going to go about trying to do
here you know there was the you know
there was not that much that Hillary
Clinton in 2008 actually wanted from
Barack Obama and so she you know except
she wanted a future in Democratic
politics and so she eventually you know
for a variety of reasons decided to make
peace pretty quick um what what what do
you think now reading the te Lees
Sanders wants and how will he go about
trying to get it yeah I mean there's
been for a long time a discussion about
whether he wanted to adjust the platform
and many Democratic advisers have told
him why nobody cares about that
certainly he wants to affect the
nominating process in many of the States
California is a good example of a place
whereas Independents have been brought
into the fold it's helped candidates
Like Bernie Sanders he would like to
take that to other states and he would
like to have some Legacy for himself
maybe not a future in the same sense
that he would if he were 35 but a future
for the next several years as he returns
to the Senate he wants to be not
forgotten and left behind but for
Hillary Clinton she has another lever to
pull it is she'd like for Bernie to come
around quickly and and on his own terms
but if he doesn't she has Donald Trump
as a lever to get his supporters on
board with her I want to switch topics
to the very bad jobs report that came
out for those Americans who are
concerned still about the economy what
are things that Hillary Clinton is
saying she do as president different
than Barack Obama that would help them
uh find jobs with uh good
wages well I think there's a number of
things first of all I wouldn't be
surprised if within the first few months
of her Administration we see a pretty
significant infrastructure bill and I
think it has a relatively decent chance
of passing because Republicans are going
to be reeling from 5 months of racist
comments from Donald Trump I think
raising the minimum wage will certainly
be part of it she's laid out a pretty
comprehensive clean energy plan so I
think there's a host of things that
she's focused on in fact I think of all
the people running for president so far
she's probably been the one who has
released the most detailed plans of
anybody not only on the economy but on a
number of other issues guys Cecil thank
you very much Margaret tal thank you
thank you coming up our next guest has
got his mind on the money and the money
on the mind he's the finance chair of
the Republican Governor Association
longtime Republican wise man Fred Malik
after this got his mind
[Music]
on
[Applause]
[Music]
next up in our parade of great great
guest tonight Republican strategist and
finance chairman of the Republican
Governor Association Fred Malik who
joins us from Washington DC Fred let me
ask you this question back on May 31st
in the Washington Post you wrote a
pretty tough oped uh about Donald Trump
after he attacks Susan Martin and you
worried about his lack of discipline and
told him he needed to change uh that was
all before the entire uh huge
controversy of Judge curiel so at this
moment uh how do you think the the the
you're making what kind of progress is
Donald Trump making and changing in a
way uh that you think is going to help
him win the presidency uh so
far well uh to my to my surprise he's
not taking my advice I I don't think
he's taking it I think he's kind of
doubled down on on some of his
criticisms although I think it's a step
in the right direction to try to step
out of it in his statement today but
nevertheless I found his statement on
Judge Cel to be rather distasteful and
discouraging there are a lot of us in
the Republican Party who want to come
around and support the nominee of our
party he's just making it more difficult
Fred um You probably talked to if not
the exact same donors we've talked to
the same kind of donors and bundlers and
big Financial supporters of the party uh
give us a sense of how freaked out
people have been in the last 72
hours well I think people have been
looking for Donald Trump once he secured
the nomination to be kind of moved more
toward a a not a Cess position but a but
a position that unifies rather than
divides I think they've looking for him
to be more presidential and to bring
people together and to and to make peace
with with with all important groups in
our country uh that are going to be so
important in in in the vote in November
and and I think there's disappointment
that he hasn't done that
yet moving in that direction if I can
just if I can interrupt you said
disappointed my guess is you've heard
more than disappointment you've heard
people freaking out and wondering is
this really our nominee is that not
true uh no it's really not true people
accept that this is our nominee look
many of us would have pined in for for
Paul Ryan a Mitt Romney or even a Jeb
Bush or a David Petraeus or Stan the
Chris or something like that it would be
great if we'd had our choice but we
didn't he won he won fair and square and
he is the nominee now you got a choice
do you support the nominee of your party
or you or don't you I think the the
point is here is people are still of an
opinion that we need to change the
direction of the country and that's why
they want to be supportive of this of
this nominee BR you said before that you
thought that uh that that Trump's
comments about Judge curiel were
distasteful today Paul Ryan said they
were the textbook definition of racist
do you agree with that or disagree with
that um I'm not going to comment on on
what a definition of racist is I put out
a tweet earlier that said I was very
disappointed in it that I found that uh
I don't remember the exact words but
even more reprehensible than his
comments on suzan Martinez I think it's
perfectly fair to question a judge's U
impartiality to do it in court but not
based on his ethnicity uh I think that's
that's that's that's wrong and I think
it uh it it really speaks so e of him
and you know what it hurts him more than
anybody else so to go to the question of
discipline that you raised in your op
bed Fred you know this this controversy
broke out now several days ago and yet
yesterday Trump was continuing until
today was continuing to go further and
further repeating these criticisms
urging his his his surrogates to repeat
them uh does that speak of a kind of
discipline that's required uh of a
nominee of either party for that matter
uh to be a successful presidential
candidate well in my uh oped I I spoke
to the lack of discipline and the fact
that he must have more discipline if
he's going to win the election uh you
got to back and think about what you're
going to say and how it's going to
affect people it's hard to believe that
he would sit back and think gee if I
attack this this judge based on his
ethnicity that's going to be a good
thing uh it it just doesn't seem it's
plausible that anybody would think
that's a good thing right so I was I was
highly disappointed that he did it and
it does speak to a lack of discipline he
needs to bring it together we want to be
there for him but unless he can bring it
together and give us a reason and show
he's a man of inclusion not exclusion
and be more tolerant of others it's
going to be very hard for for us all to
Rally behind him Fred can you explain
the constellation of trump super packs
and how a wealthy Republican who wants
to help him should decide which one to
give
too well I think you're overing super
packs to start with uh and I don't
understand the constellation I think
they're uh if Sheldon Adon is giving 100
million the one that's one I'd want to
be associated with but I think I think
even more important than the super packs
and something that's not been reported
on too much is the fact that you need
money in your campaign chest not just in
the super pack it's the campaign that
hires the people that run the
organization that put out the ads that
you can that you can Target put out some
Direct Mail uh that develops
organizations in the states these are
organizations that have been put
together over decades by the clintons
and and several years by any other
presidential candidate he's got two
months to do it he's going to have a
serious Financial disadvantage Hillary
Clinton all right FR Mal sorry we got to
cut you off get to break thank you for
coming on the show when we come back
David French we'll talk about why he
decided not forun for President right
right after
[Music]
this
last week all the political world was
wondering who was Bill Crystal talking
about when he suggested that there was
going to be a thirdparty presidential
bid by someone with a good chance of
winning turned out he was talking about
our next guest David French who's a
lawyer a writer for National Review a
veteran of the Iraq War and a Tennessean
French announc on Sunday he was not
going to enter the race and he joins us
now to talk about all of this thank you
for coming thanks for having me when was
the very first time in your life someone
suggested to you or you thought about
the notion of running for president
about a little less than two weeks ago
uh meeting with Bill Crystal and talking
about the times that we're in and uh you
know I think that there's almost two
categories of people that are emerging
right now those who understand the
gravity of the challenge we're facing in
politics now and how serious for example
the threat to of Donald Trump is not
just to politics but to civil society as
we've seen in this in this judge
controversy and those who think we're in
some sort of land of Politics as Usual
just with a little bit more
outrageousness to it uh I'm in the in
the camp that that believes and
understands this is something else
entirely and when other people weren't
stepping up and Bill asked me if I'd
consider it uh I I said yes I would
consider it so did he tweet when he
tweeted to suggest that it was happening
because he had you in mind was that with
your authorization did you led him to
believe you were going to do it uh I I
that was a surprise I have to say well
surprised he did but but did he have
reason to believe that at that point you
were going to do it I he had reason to
believe I was thinking about it yeah
absolutely I mean he wouldn't have just
tweeted that out as some sort of well
but he tweeted that it was happening not
that you were thinking about it will
happen you know it's easy to read an
awful lot into 140 characters it was it
was a process under consideration and
you know I I fully recognize uh
gentlemen that uh I don't have name
recognition uh but I also recognize and
I heard this analogy today that the the
demand for an alternative it's almost
like a pressure cooker that there is an
enormous amount of pinup demand even
people who are supporting Trump are
doing so very reluctantly there's a
segment of Democrats supporting Hillary
Clinton very reluctantly so there's pent
up demand there we need the right person
to release that demand into our culture
into our politics and so in recognizing
the pent up demand you know I wanted to
give it serious thought to see if you
know there was a chance that I could
that I could be helpful in that process
was there was there one decisive factor
or what were the the decisive like the
key decisive factors that led you to
conclude that you know this was just not
something for you to do you know I I'll
tell you it's it's very simple uh I
believed honestly at the end of the day
even though there wasn't really anyone
stepping up uh waiting in the wings at
that time that I would end up doing more
harm than good um that I'd heard a lot
of people saying well you know you you
have a a good biography and people will
like you when they get to know you but
you know in that circumstance that's a
huge challenge there's a need for a
person with an existing constituency and
if I went forward and it fizzled which
was a likelihood um then it would give a
misimpression to the American people
into the larger body politic that
there's fewer people like me than there
really are people who are are uh
disgusted with the status quo and so
it's better for there to be somebody who
has that constituency to take advantage
of the 65 % of American people are
willing to look for a third alternative
there are people um friends of Bill
Crystal and others who right now are
back at it especially in the wake of the
judge curiel comments trying to find
someone to pick up this mantle are you
actively involved in that process at all
uh I have been involved in meetings
where where we directly talking about
that and I know there will be people who
will be approached specifically and and
I hope that you know they can consider
it in a different atmosphere that I did
which is not with everyone talking about
it but take some time with their
families and think about it quietly run
the traps on it take a look at the
actual numbers the actual work that's
been done and I think they'll see it's
very viable I assume you're not
interested in breaking news on who those
people are right now on the show Under
The Golden Rule of I would not like to
do to others that I the same experience
I had no so what kind of people you
talking about people that will be
approached I mean again people like you
or people who are more conventionally uh
suited maybe to running for presid I
think if there's one thing we learned in
this process with me uh Guinea so happy
to serve as a guinea pig here um was
that uh number one there is demand there
were people contacting me from all over
the country I'm willing to quit my job
tomorrow to help you but if you want to
get the $25 million or so that's
necessary to really explode out on those
ballots you need that existing
constituency and that's something that I
lacked and so you know the message that
we can give to somebody else is pretty
clear if you have that existing
constituency if you either have money
yourself or you have access to
fundraising quick access to fundraising
Network it is there all that stuff you
hear about a ballot access problem being
insurmountable false all that stuff that
you hear about third party candidates
never have a chance so when since when
has this cycle been normal so um the
French presidential campaign lasted
about a week a little bit less well
we'll call it the potential yes uhuh um
I know you had some unpleasant aspects
of it but just talk about what it was
like for your family to see you on the
news everywhere and people talking about
you in a way that had never happened
before what was that like in the UP UP
side of it well you know uh well was
there an upside I'm trying to think um'
be kind of heady no not really I mean
you know our family has already
experienced the downside of being
against Trump and and not and that
circumstance not from the Trump campaign
but the Trump supporters um it was a
circumstance you know look uh my older
kids understand what's going on my wife
understands what's going on she's
opposed to Trump and to Clinton and she
knows the gravity of the time so it was
a weighty thing it wasn't a it wasn't a
heady moment you're a man who thinks of
everything so and I'm sure you thought
ahead let's hear your what was the
Zinger you were going to use on the
debate against Trump let's hear one of
those zingers come on the Zinger that I
was going to use you know all I was
going to do with Trump was remind him of
what he said you know he was going to
try to pretend to the American people
that he was a serious candidate for
president and I was going to remind the
American people that he thinks that
Exxon can help beat Isis would you been
nervous in the debates oh of course I
mean I'm a a rational human being who
wouldn't be nervous in the debates I'm
sure Trump was at least once or twice
you don't nervous
now uh you know I hide it well maybe I
have a better I'm predicting right now
you're going to be an excellent Jeopardy
answer at some point my prediction maybe
in the $200 category David French of
Tennessee thank you for joining us thank
you when we come back we follow Bernie
Sanders followers around California as a
nomination season wrapped up what we
learned after
this
[Music]
[Applause]
since Bernie Sanders launched his
presidential bid 13 months ago the
Democratic dominating contest has been
something that nobody thought it would
be interesting last night when the AP
called the race for Hillary Clinton it
only fueled Sanders supporters distrust
of the mainstream media and the
political establishment as this phase of
the campaign ends with Sanders all but
certain to fall short of the nomination
we wanted to know what the final leg has
been like for his voters in California
where he's been barnstorming for the
past two weeks what we found was that
just as California is a microcosm of
America the Sanders phenomenon in the
Golden State is a microcosm of the
movement he unexpectedly inspired all
across the
country Senator wondering that the final
days of this primary season have you
have any moments to reflect on
everything that this campaign has for
you and all people you've
met what I see when I look out to crowds
of many many thousands of people when I
go out into the farm country here uh in
California and I see Latino kids and
black kids and white kids and working
class people out there many people who
have not been involved in the political
process I see such incredible hope in
their eyes see that's why we love him
because he not he sees the people he
sees in their faces he knows us who
think it is appropriate to tell us that
they love Muhammad Ali but they hate
Muslims yeah the first time he he hugged
a Muslim a hijabi on TV that's where I
was like we're we're in we're in deep we
can't go
back just like an old Jewish guy you
know but he his message is what's
powerful how am I going to handle June
7th how am I going to handle you know
the results am I going to be you know
really depressed and really disappointed
no matter what the outcome of this
election is Bernie started a revolution
amongst the
Millennials dude watch this look Bernie
Sanders was shaking everybody's hands
and when he came to me I screamed I was
like Bernie I gave him a hug thank you
for a thank you so much for giving me a
[Music]
voice
a lot of people don't understand how
hard it is to go through the immigration
system I've been through it myself so I
spent 25 years trying to get
legal so I understand how complicated it
is and he seems to understand it as well
when when he first came out even we were
like all right I don't know if he's
going to make uh a huge Splash but he
will be able to move people to the left
just the way he speaks and the way he's
able to articulate everything so clearly
my
11-year-old he was able to understand
what Bernie is
saying I'm a member of the Onie per
Bernie is
ba it's amazing how
authenticity sounds really good and he
doesn't seem super polished I mean half
the time his hair is unkempt but I would
hear him talk about oligarchy and sort
of a rig system and I started looking
into him maybe a few years ago before he
was running and I couldn't believe he
was a career Pol politician I thought he
was just some Fringe dude but he's been
doing that for a long time and and I
trust that message there's so much
momentum going toward towards Bernie and
you know even if it's a third party that
that comes up out of this this next few
months there's people that are not going
to
stop and so we've just been like really
busy we had like lacrosse games we had
prom I mean like we had stuff to do
today but we were like we got to go like
let's go anyone know the average
contribution
$27 the $27 thing the casino capitalism
the 1% the billionaires and millionaires
so many kids we know like just identify
with what he says and I think there's
just like a lot of frustration with
especially at least for me like economic
inequality I think it's hard for people
to realize the privilege that they had
and I think he's mentioned that a lot
before but like there are a lot of like
kids and teenagers out there who aren't
afforded the same opportunities as we
are and I'd like to know that they like
would have the same like chances to like
get an education as we do I don't think
it's like sad that there's an end I
think all of his policies and everything
that he's talking about it still has
momentum when I was a student at
Berkeley that's when I first heard about
Bernie Sanders one of his main campaign
points is the whole tuition free college
people are tired of going to debt just
so they can get an education just so
they can get a better life for
themselves so that's that's a huge
selling point for college students it's
kind of still Taboo in some circles but
he's the one guy who says take weed off
of the schedule one list stop punishing
people for smoking weed and guess what
you know college students smoke a lot of
weed my first political rally ever I
served in the military considered myself
libertarian for a while and then slowly
converted the once in A- lifetime
opportunity to be able to cast a vote
for a guy who actually believes what I
believe Win Lose or Draw I can't I can't
pass that up
yeah bir the little bird landing on that
this little thing managed to find its
way in the middle of it all birdie I
mean that's like an iconic one he's just
a cute man he's like a cute old man it
was just really endearing and really
lovable that was a really cool moment
for his campaign when the bird meme came
out that that like destroyed the group
chat um it froze you can't script that
stuff even though I had kind of an
affinity to the clintons before just
thinking about some of the policies that
he had and that she supported makes me
you know think I should be more
independent about and vote for the
issues that are important now and
there's a lot if if Bernie broke off and
did independent would you vote for
Bernie as an independent no I don't
think he would get in that way right and
I think we disagree on that a little
bit when I look out at those young
people and workingclass people who want
real change in this country who are
prepared to be involved in the political
process I get very very inspired and
that in fact is
exactly where I get my energy to go
forward
[Applause]
our thanks to the great Griffin Hammond
and his valet Matt Negan you guys do not
go to Tijana you'll never come back all
right up next Paul Ryan didn't only talk
about Donald Trump at his morning news
conference the speaker of the house also
unveiled the first in a series of new
policy proposals we will discuss what he
said about the Republican agenda in the
next Congress right after this and don't
forget if you're watching us in
Washington DC you can listen to us as
well on the radio radio at Bloomberg
99.1 FM we will be right back
[Music]
today at a press conference in
Washington DC the house Speaker Paul
Ryan launched his election year policy
agenda with a set of anti-poverty
proposals listing problems with the
country's current social welfare system
system and job training and some
prescriptions for how to fix things
joining us now to talk about that plan
Ryan's effort to keep his party unified
and more to smart people Lon he Chen the
former policy director for Mitt Romney's
presidential campaign joins us from
Stanford at at Hoover institution where
he is Affiliated and here in the studio
mike duim a senior strategist for
Governor Christie including on his
presidential campaign and a former
political director of the Republican
National Committee gentlemen thank you
for coming he like a big cheese Lon he
let me ask you about uh speaker Ryan's
proposals again dealing a lot with the
safety net and trying to make programs
more efficient on that and job training
what did the speaker proposed today this
task force proposed that you think could
find bipartisan consensus in Congress
and around the
country you know Mark today was a
historic day we actually had policy from
the US House of Representatives I mean
this is a really remarkable effort on
the part of Paul Ryan and his colleagues
it's a strong agenda an anti-poverty
agenda that includes consolidation of a
lot of programs to help people make them
more efficient I think that could see
bipartisan support there's this notion
of of pay for performance or pay for
Success so the federal government is
only funding programs that work I think
that could get bipartisan support and
there's also uh just a really strong
notion of reinstituting work and that's
something that Democrats supported back
in 1996 with welfare reform and they
could support again in looking at how to
reform our anti-poverty program so
really a strong robust agenda and I'm
really glad you guys are covering it
Lonnie let me ask you a question that
mixes policy and politics before I turn
to doam here which is is it not the case
that in a presidential election year
that traditionally that the only hope
for policies to be Advanced as if the
Presidential nominee advances them do
you agree with that or do you think Paul
Ryan could really make progress with
this agenda even if Trump doesn't care
about
it well I I think precisely because of
the dynamic between Trump and Paul Ryan
uh this policy agenda could be something
that gets some attention because you
know Trump has been a policy free zone I
don't see that changing I don't think
that's his strength uh and that's not
something he focuses on so if he says
look Paul Ryan you do the policy then it
is a great opportunity I think for Paul
Ryan to be out there talking about these
issues it's a different question whether
people are actually interested and
whether it gets covered but even when we
did policy on a presidential campaign
I'm not sure too many people covered it
anyway uh so the chances are decent for
Paul's agenda to to move forward I think
Mike let me just ask you if you were
working for Donald Trump right now um
and the Paul Ryan's poverty proposals
came out how would you if you went to
Donald Trump given his strengths and
weaknesses as a candidate how would you
say Mr Trump we really should adopt this
policy here's how you should go and sell
it here's how you can make this your own
in many ways I'd Embrace those policies
because often times as Republicans I
think we get seen as uh heartless and
callous and only caring about fiscal
issues and I think when you start
talking about poverty I really applaud
uh speaker Ryan for doing this I think
Republicans who've been successful
especially on the state level have done
well talking about issues that go beyond
that in terms of empowering people
economically empowering them through
education and choice in that way so I
really think it's something that would
be good for the party long term I agree
with Lon that often times policy gets
lost in this but with proliferation of
cable television and online issues I I
think that the uh the ability for this
to be discussed more robustly just based
on those changes will will help Lon let
me ask you this as Devil's Advocate
these are talking about Federal programs
what about the 10th Amendment why why
aren't these why shouldn't Governors
deal with poverty in their states and
not try to make Washington more
efficient great question I mean part of
this part of what Paul Ryan is proposing
is to give States more of a
uh in in how anti-poverty programs are
handled but you know some of this
coordination does come from the federal
level but absolutely I think you're
going to see that as a theme in more and
more of these policy rollouts that Paul
Ryan's doing over the next six weeks
which is how there are programs that are
working at the federal level and those
that aren't how they might be
Consolidated how the states can play a
bigger role I think that's going to be a
theme across issue areas ranging all the
way to healthcare uh in the next couple
weeks Mike I got to ask you about Donald
Trump and these latest comments Governor
Christie your boss and friend was not
particularly strong in denouncing what
um what Donald Trump said many others
have been when the this chapter of this
campaign is written What will what will
people remember about what's happened
since Donald Trump raised the issue of
the judge and his Mexican an I think
it'll be seen as a as a big mistake I
think it's uh it's not good for the
party it's not good for his campaign uh
the judge is he's from Indiana I mean
this is this is a mistake and it's bad
and it's wrong and I think uh I think I
think Governor chrisy is somebody who's
known him for many years and so sees him
differently uh in terms of that way and
doesn't judge him by one set of comments
but I think certainly as we look back on
the campaign uh this will be seen as a
chapter but it'll be seen a chapter of
many things that he said that are going
to be questionable and I think all of us
who've been through the primary process
and throughout have have thought many
times that boy that's the one that's
going to undo it and it doesn't and it
doesn't because uh seemingly going
counterintuitive to what everybody says
is what you know his voters and
supporters uh are are finding appealing
in him but this case I think will be
seen as something that was a big mistake
and something that people are right to
uh to object to let me ask you a
question we discussed in the a block
real quick is this the statement he put
out today is it enough I mean there's a
lot of Republicans freaking out over the
course of the last 72 hours donors
electeds Etc Trump put a statement out
today you've seen the statement is that
enough to stop the bleeding I think it's
a step in the right direction but I
don't think it's enough I I I think he's
got to turn the page quite frankly as a
as for his campaign he he should be
talking about Hill Hillary Clinton not
about Trump University not about a
federal judge in Indiana he should be
talking about differences uh in policy
between he and Hillary Clinton from a
big aspirational point of view I agree
with Lon he that it's do not a lot of
deep policy but there are major policy
differences going forward and quite
frankly I don't think there'll be unity
in the party until they focus on the
differences between he and Hillary
Clinton Mike Dam thank you Lon Chen many
degrees none as far as I know though
from Trump you thank you very much we'll
be right back with some final thoughts
about the primary contests being held
today
[Music]
[Applause]
how taken back how surprised were you at
the call last night that Hillary Clinton
is a presumptive democratic know what I
was upset is what the AP did um they got
on the phone as I understand that and
they started hounding super delegates to
tell them in an anonymous way who they'd
be voting for and the night before the
largest primary biggest Primary in the
whole process they make this
announcement so I was really
disappointed in what the uh AP
did Sanders talking to NBC's Lester Holt
in California today um what's your view
about the AP call last night you know I
mean I think news organizations should
publish their tally but they should
say this is not final until the actual
votes are I think the AP was fine but I
think everybody who's written the words
like she's clinched she's secured not
true she's not Clint she's not secured
she's on track but she's not done either
one of those things all right keep
refreshing Bloomberg politics.com
tonight for all your updates on the
nomination contest in California New
Jersey and the other states coming up on
Bloomberg TV Emily Chang talking to
Sanford University President John
Hennessy John Hennessy man he's a smart
dude that's up on Bloomberg West we will
be back tomorrow Mark and I will we'll
be in Cleveland Cleveland Cleveland
special show from the S side of the
Republican convention until then we say
to you
[Music]
sayura
[Applause]
[Music]